these are not just statistics to me we
know that long-term unemployment is
devastating to workers and their
families Janet Yellen feels your pain
the 67 year old economist has spent her
life in academia and the halls of
Washington but friends say her focus has
always been the human side of economics
Janet Yellen is an unusually empathetic
person she looks beyond the numbers and
statistics at what is really going on in
people's minds and how people are
suffering Yellen was an overachiever
from the start a high school classmate
from Brooklyn calls her the smartest
girl in the class by far she was the
valedictorian at Brown University's
Women's College in 1967 and earned her
doctorate at Yale where her adviser was
Nobel Prize winner James Tobin one of
the most influential liberal economists
of his era Yellen concentrated a
research unemployment she theorized the
cutting wages lowers productivity
because it makes workers feel underpaid
and unhappy she spent more than a decade
on the faculty at Berkeley before
President Clinton appointed her to the
Fed Board of Governors in 1994 and then
brought her to the White House as his
top economic adviser politics weren't
her thing though she left the
administration after two years to go
back to teaching in 2004 Yellen returned
to the central bank first as president
of the San Francisco fed and since 2010
back in Washington as vice chairman
under Ben Bernanke she's been a strong
advocate for the Fed stimulus programs
and makes no secret of the fact that her
focus once again is on jobs with
employment so far from its maximum level
and with inflation running below the
committee's 2 percent objective
I believe it's appropriate for progress
in the labor market to take center stage
in the conduct of monetary policy